cool та
і мінету ахмад через конвер анти-віч
змінюється і магазин по заду
джеба готова ден роботи торговий this
bar личку в район ук росберг що і на
пробу з ринку квіти вин проти він 28
років що дня привозіть
apache це фрукти олл-іни жодна знай
подальших фруктових порівняти crois
Берга знаходите знову за грізних на дні
30 бар з неї від риму за видами вони про
розрив контракту, а вже 30 вересня
чоловік узда то приватний інвест
він викупив but enough наповніть врангеля
і ви відро мантуї що час творить на
елітний житловий комплекс
нині ісус і готувати це боротьби за них
його ось шавок рамочку алла комарно
народилася а тут вкрасти боротьбу у нас би
rapid пішли в цю його Стів кай тобою
частина в акціях протесту всі заряди того
а б магазин bizim бак altay у владних
за іншу руду кути за вище тобто вкриє
вирву bizim келих означаючи на шакрам
нитки самий так наш кордон ми з такс
прямо йому ящеру здорово над ним я багата
людей думає так саму ми не можемо у до
золота ще б нас забрав ліцей магазин
кройцберг популярний район Берліна
виконані туристів то кафе та виду ми
своїми маленькими магазинчиками там і
багато нових мешкать і так хоче тут
а ти давиш кінцевик хоче всю
тенденцію на суді
сидорів чаю засіки оренда експерти
ринку на руку масті поважається нормальним
я вищий ніж для міжнародних біля місця
і ченцями повно дешевого шатла нас
правді вдосталь
алого нас заходьте на ювідерм антого них
будемо лях з вибитим розсмоктуванням на во
роту думати ще можна все дешеве
зніматися найкращий житло за рахунок
штат консультативного права людей на
метильні не дасть нам to skip the small
опротестували з ціни на сьогодні і
шкірну сара думаєш contigo улусі
врангеля тієї близько 2
ці порядком націю ахмета шили скана
є не спи нота в інтернеті наявності в
жопу над 100000 для bitch nicky
ми не хочемо взуті на сторінках яку
лея кройцберг ми знаходимо і того а бути і
на оренду пастино зростала і люди
такий же ви тут же багата на руки нам про клуб
самі пишете воду золото
ми хочемо а розум завищувати якщо тут нашому
районі
ахмад шалі скан мої на світ ставків живіт
і боротьбу на витек чуєва стаєш
даєте безнадійним і вину 3 мій піт ринку
алла переносимо ventrac на іншого ти
далі і поїхав магазинчиків працює
забігав сталь